on va plus loin avec aujourd'hui à mes
côtés françois durpaire historien
bonjour françois bourgeois raphaël et
bruno daroux de la rédaction de france
24 bonjour bonojean rafale les tensions
n'ont pas l'air de se dégonfler en
ukraine au contraire russes et
biélorusses entament leurs manoeuvres
militaires tant redoutée trente mille
soldats russes y participent d'après les
occidentaux qui continuent de pointer
plus généralement la présence de plus de
100 mille hommes envoyés par moscou dans
la région écoutez ce qu'en dit l'otan
suivi du chef de la diplomatie française
jean yves le drian
l'exercice en biélorussie qui n'est pas
loin de l'endroit où nous parlons
aujourd'hui est extrêmement préoccupant
or quand il s'agit en effet d'un
exercice massif comprenant non seulement
un grand nombre de troupes russes mais
aussi des capacités haut de gamme
c'est pourquoi nous faisons de notre
mieux de la manière la plus sincère et
la plus ouverte pour emprunter la voie
de la diplomatie d'apatow déploiement
sais pas je considère que la situation
est très grave il ne faut pas se leurrer
la russie s'est donné les moyens de
lancer une nouvelle agression contre
contre l'ukraine c'est une réalité alors
à ma connaissance il n'y a pas de
décision de prise à cet égard mais
lorsque vous avez 125 mille hommes à la
frontière russo ukrainienne
lorsque vous avez des grandes manoeuvres
qui sont en cours qui vont commencer
aujourd'hui que ce soit en bélarus avec
des forces russes et des forces de
belarus et en mer noire avec des
manoeuvres navales hausse très
significative
oui il ya de quoi être inquiet la
situation est très grave
bruno daroux c'est là maintenant qu'on
est en lice que la situation peut à tout
moment basculer disons qu'on est entré
là dans une séquence
un peu plus tendue encore que ça ne
l'était même si tout au long de cette
crise un peu interminable maintenant
quand même on alterne on a l'impression
que les russes alterne entre la tension
puis le dialogue est à nouveau
l'attention voilà pour que tout ça
maintiennent une forte pression sur
l'ukraine et sur les occidentaux quoi
qu'il en soit effectivement l'actualité
d'aujourd'hui c'est quand même un
renforcement des capacités militaires
autour de l'ukraine donc comme le disait
voilà le genre yves le drian est
effectivement 125 mille hommes basés
côté russe le long de la frontière
ukrainienne et puis en biélorussie il ya
donc ces exercices militaires conjoints
alors selon les occidentaux ces
exercices réunissent 30000 soldats
russes c'est à dire quatre fois plus que
ce qui se fait d'ordinaire ça dure
jusqu'au 20 février il faudra voir un
peu déjà si ces exercices se déroulent
dans dans la zone dédiée en biélorussie
dans une ville qui est au nord-ouest de
la frontière avec l'ukraine
s'il ya ensuite des mouvements de troupe
à surveiller évidemment ça de près c'est
vrai qu'il ya des armements assez
sophistiqué beaucoup d'avions de chasse
qui ont été montrés par le ministère
russe de la défense et puis
parallèlement effectivement six navires
de guerre russes qui sont en crimée qui
vont procéder à des manoeuvres navales
donc évidemment les ukrainiens ne
peuvent que se sentir de plus en plus
encerclé on est là voilà dans un moment
de de tension on était en début de
semaine dans un moment plus de dialogues
toujours cette stratégie russe un peu si
vous voulez de de l'incertitude du
maintien de la pression on ne sait pas
exactement ce qu'ils veulent et ils
maintiennent leurs demandes notamment
concernant le nom d'allah gisement de
l'otan qui reste inacceptable pour les
occidentaux dialogue de sourds dit ont
d'ailleurs des deux côtés mais pour
preuve un que la situation peut basculer
françois durpaire on apprend que le chef
d'état major américain le général marc
miley a eu une conversation téléphonique
avec son homologue bélarusse et ce afin
de prévenir tout incident malencontreux
washington prend 1 clairement depuis
plusieurs jours la menace très au
sérieux trop
washington dit quasiment tous les jours
et depuis longtemps
l'invasion de l'ukraine est quasi
imminente alors ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que là on a vraiment un junkie à
la manoeuvre dans l'équipe c'est lui qui
connaît quasiment le mieux la région
dans son équipe de diplomatie puisque il
était déjà à la manoeuvre en 2014
c'était le vice président vous vous
souvenez qui a les six fois en ukraine
pendant le mandat d'obama est dans
l'équipe d'obama c'était l'un des
bellicistes c'était l'un de ceux qui
très rapidement
l'équipe d'obama qu'est ce qu'ils
voulaient faire quand ils sont arrivés
voulait très clairement tourné la page
de la guerre froide se dire c'est
terminé faisons nous on est tourné vers
la louisiane à chine voilà le fameux 8,7
et ça n'a pas marché du nous donc
première enseignements de tout ça by
donne 10 avec poutine ça va pas le faire
on va pas pouvoir rester comme on a
envie de le faire et à la russie mais à
sa tête il ya une personnalité qui ne
veut pas tourner cette maj la deuxième
chose c'est que les alliés sont
importants et l'expérience de bail donne
c'est de dire toute sanction et vous
voyez un peu les efforts qu'il fait pour
qu'à voir les 27 de l'union européenne
avec lui c'est très important est
également et puis il est toujours sur
cette ligne belliciste vous vous
souvenez que pendant la campagne
électorale joe biden a dit moi je vais
donner des armes à l'ukraine 200
millions de dollars d'armes et c'était
l'un des seuls points de convergence
avec donald rabat où il a dit il a même
félicité de dames train pour sa fermeté
et le fait que là il décide de de
soutenir l'ukraine donc on a là un job
and qui en plus il yal'affaire afghane
on lui a reproché de ne pas avoir écouté
ses services de renseignements sur
l'imminence de graves problèmes en
acadie ce temps donc là voilà il essaie
vraiment de jouer plutôt du côté de
quelque chose qui peut vraiment être
tragique dans les heures qui viennent et
en tout cas il a sur sa ligne c'est ali
de la special relationship comme on dit
un bruno daroux les britanniques qui
renforcent leur présence militaire en
pologne les européens au sens large
puisque les britanniques se sont
extraits l'union européenne mais
géographiquement ils sont toujours dans
cet ensemble ils ont des armes de
dissuasion contre moscou à eux seuls à
écouter à eux seuls ce ce à quoi on
assiste là cesser l'envoi de quelques
centaines
de soldats britanniques en l'occurrence
mais au sein de l'otan genre évidemment
il s'agit pas d' europe de la défense il
faut noter effectivement que la
diplomatie britannique maintenant
qu'elle est effectivement sorti de
l'union européenne a retrouvé cette
relation spéciale on peut parler quand
même de quasi alignement des positions
de bruce johnson sur celle de joe biden
dans cette crise il l'a répété
aujourd'hui
donc les européens oui ils ont des des
fins d arme de dissuasion ils ont
préparé un paquet de sanctions contre
contre la russie mais en fin de session
nord stream aussi à la question nord
stream ils sont si dépendants notamment
l'allemagne aussi dépendant du gazole du
gaz russe pour sa priverait la russie de
beaucoup de recettes donc oui ils ont
des armes mais surtout ils font tout
pour
essayer éviter d'être exclu du jeu
diplomatique si on se souvient dans un
premier temps la lumière poutine avait
dû mais moi je ne parle que directement
qu'avec nouvelle donne puisque c'est là
que tout se décide on a vu alors ces
derniers jours notamment que la tournée
de diplomatique d'emmanuel macron qu'il
revenait un peu dans le dans le jeu hein
il ya eu cet affichage avec
le président français le chancelier
allemand le président polonais bon donc
c'est une de weimar voilà voilà ça ça va
par contre quand aujourd'hui la
commission européenne envoie une lettre
à moscou signée par l'ensemble des 27
pays vient moscou dit non mais moi je
veux pas parler avec cette entité dont
convoi en fait le problème de l'union
européenne c'est que à la fois côté
russe et aussi un peu côté américain on
n'a pas trop envie que l'europe
s'affirme comme une puissance
diplomatique au mans sont vus ou un mac
ou encore beaucoup de travail oui
comment sont vus ces initiatives à
washington notamment la l'offensive
diplomatique d'emmanuel mars c'est vrai
que du côté de bagdad on tient comprend
l'importance de l'union européenne on
sait à la fois les limites en fait d'une
union européenne qui n'est pas unie sur
le plan diplomatique mais on sait que
c'est important notamment pour les
sanctions maintenant ce dont on est en
train de parler c'est pas de la crise
ukrainienne en fait pour l'historien ce
que c'est tout à fait normal ce qui est
en train de se passer c'est toujours
comme ça dans l'histoire un pays qui
perd une guerre hélas il n'a pas perdu
n'importe quelle guerre l'union
soviétique qui vous parle et à berlin
n'a guère fringant après la gaffe faute
s'il ya 30 ans quand vous perdez une
guerre vous perdez une guerre à votre
détriment et donc géopolitiquement c'est
une catastrophe l' explosion du rss etc
et puis trente ans plus tard parfois ses
vingt ans plus tard parfois 40 ans vous
redis finissais les termes quand c'est à
votre avantage on a dû modernisation de
l'armée russe poutine a pris ce temps le
temps qu'il fallait pour dire et cette
fois le temps est venu de renégocier la
géopolitique d'après guerre froide à mon
avantage c'est pas la sphère ukrainien
évidemment donc ça veut dire que vous
avez entendu la phrase d'emmanuel macron
au début de la semaine ça s'était plutôt
juste il n'y aura pas de sécurité
européenne sans sécurité russes et pour
les russes l'union européenne ils
n'entreront jamais de dans le temps
c'est très clairement dirigé contre eux
donc ça veut dire que du côté poutine il
voit quand même de manière assez juste
il faut préserver les intérêts de l'ue
de la russie j'allais presque dire de
l'union soviétique comment c'est
compliqué parce que les états unis
veulent exactement inverse ils disent il
faut que l'otan on puisse encore à
intégrer de nouvelles nations dans le
temps alors il faut être inventif
aujourd'hui sur le plan diplomatique
est ce que c'est un moratoire est ce que
c'est un moratoire sur 7 portes ouvertes
en disant l'ukraine pourra peut-être un
jour etc mais 2050 ça prend mais très
préservé les intérêts sans que les états
unis ne soit voilà renégocier évidemment
rediscuter les accords d'helsinki parce
que ce qu'on a fait en 1975 en pleine
guerre froide pour arriver à la détente
pourquoi ne pourrait-on pas aujourd'hui
le faire et puis quelque chose d'encore
plus ancien que l'historien connaît le
droit des peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes
est ce qu'on pourrait pas réactiver
cette vieille notion du 19e siècle
aujourd'hui ça donne la révolution
orange saberi que et qu'en pensent les
peuples aujourd'hui référendum sous
contrôle international enfin on n'est
pas là pour apporter des évolutions mais
il va falloir en tout cas que les
gouvernants eux en trouve c'est dans ce
contexte que l'on voit les tensions
sociales apparu en amérique du nord se
répandre ici en europe les convois de la
liberté sème un peu partout après paris
c'est bruxelles qui interdit le
rassemblement d'automobilistes prévue
lundi prochain pour protester contre les
contraintes vaccinale écouter d'ottawa à
la france les attentes de quelques-uns
des manifestants
je n'ai pas voté pour lui
je veux juste
justin si tu regardes ça je veux que tu
quitte mes fonctions je veux que tu
partes complète et
je pense que cela a inspiré beaucoup de
néo zélandais a sorti réagir parce que
si les gens restent assis et ne disent
rien personne n'entendra notre voix
de soutenir le convoi des libertés a on
a été tellement heureux de voir ce qui
se passait au canada et de voir ce qui
se passe maintenant en europe dans le
monde on vient soutenir tous ceux qui
vont partir pour nos libertés pour nous
c'est une contestation du vaccin et plus
largement à des politiques en place est
une nouvelle manière de contester et
pouvoir démocratiquement élu une remise
en cause finalement la démocratie
représentative à laquelle on assiste à
une certaine manière oui en tout cas là
ce qui se passe en france un qui doit
normalement déboucher dans la capitale
française puis après à bruxelles même si
à bruxelles à paris et niamey fait
comprendre que ce ne serait pas
autorisée donc on va voir quand même ce
qui se passe ce week end oui bien sûr il
ya des antilles passe et à des anti
vaccins mais il ya aussi un parfum de
gilet jaune qui qui revient notamment il
ya aussi des partisans des règlements
enfin c'est très hétéroclite mais une
remise en cause de l'ordre politique
établi effectivement une demande là
encore ça ça fait penser au gilet jaune
de prise en compte des difficultés c'est
à dire après les hausses des prix de
l'énergie et sens et c'est sur le thème
on peut plus vivre comme ça donc voilà
c'est des revendications très très et
héroïque qui vont effectivement jusqu'à
la demande de démission du gouvernement
français du président emmanuel macron de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat
françois c'est finalement voilà une
contestation des élections ça rappelle
un peu ce qui s'est passé au capitole on
retrouve au canada le tropisme dans un
pays où on pensait le radicalisme
définitivement bannis ou la radicalité
en tout cas vanille exactement on a des
canadiens devant la house of commons
d'ottawa avec les mêmes menaces qu sur
le capitole aux états unis qui
d'ailleurs ont les mêmes références qu
un homme ils sont membres de qian voyez
des drapeaux des états confédérés
d'employés très clairement plutôt
raciste du sud américain c'est pas du
tout la tradition canadienne et même des
drapeaux nazis il faut le dire dans ces
manifestations ce qui fait que quand
vous regardez les sondages aujourd'hui
au canada vous avez un rejet massif de
ce qui est en train de se passer des
fameux convoi de la liberté en dix ans
les canadiens la liberté c'est pas c'est
parce qu'on voit là un ce tropisme là
plutôt exporter des états unis c'est pas
nous les canadiens nous on est un peuple
multiculturelle on a un peuple tolérant
c'est pas ce qui est en train de se
passer en revanche
il faut quand même dire qu'il ya
certains cas des ja et certains
américains qui sont véritablement lassé
par ce qui est en train de se passer par
les mesures sanitaires vous avez vu
qu'aujourd'hui raphaël l'état de new
york a dit c'est terminé les masques
c'est le dixième états américains
démocrates à dire la même chose et là
c'est pas d'être en piste c'est des
démocrates qui disent là on n'en peut
plus le nombre de cas est passé de 800
mille ans quelques dans quelques
semaines à 200 milles encore 2000 morts
par jour néanmoins merci françois
durpaire merci bruno daroux c'était on
va plus loin place à présent focus et
c'est un marathon électoral qui débute
au